that light was perfect what made you
think of that no no I think I saw it in
a comic book somewhere
you have to look around corners and see
into the shadows Cobbins of gadgets lots
of deep in vigilantes are nuts
you are thus afraid of the competition
but he changed
[Music]
cuz I've asked for only big in that
other city you're gonna tell me who you
are
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie huge news they
finally cast the Batwoman they even
dropped that trailer before they ever
cast her maybe they had cast her and
they were just keeping it secret while
they were locking down the contract then
they cut that promo but we got to break
this down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's a new round of that
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video so if you missed
the news this morning they cast Ruby
Rose as Kate Cain bat woman now she's
the version that most people think of
when they think of bat woman she's the
second version of the character
officially but she's the one that's been
appearing in the comics most recently
she was in Batman bad blood I'll play a
clip from that cuz it gives you a pretty
good idea for the character but if you
have no idea who Ruby Rose is she's
actually a really big name I didn't
expect them to get someone that big
usually the problem with a lot of CW
television shows is they get somebody
that you've never seen before that maybe
came from soaps or they came from
another CW TV show which is OK for
smaller series like when you're doing a
cute drama TV show I think that works a
little bit better but when you're
playing someone as big as Batwoman you
need to get a name it's a pretty iconic
character so you can't just pick up
anybody off the street so if you haven't
seen any of her stuff most people
initially got to know her on orange is
the new black where she was hella naked
she blew up on that then she did a
series of really big action films like
she was in Resident Evil the triple x
sequel John wick she was actually really
fun in John wick this is just like a
quick montage of some of her action
scenes just to give you an idea for what
she's capable of
[Music]
so you have an idea for why she made
their list they need an actress that can
do all the action all the Batwoman stuff
where she's actually being a vigilante
but they also need someone that can do
the drama stuff when she's walking
around as Kate Caine during the day so
the other noticeable thing is that she's
actually a pretty young actress so I
would say that in terms of age she has
parody with Oliver and Barry Barry's a
little bit younger than all of her but I
would pin her somewhere around her mid
to late 20s like she's probably been
Batwoman for a couple years when this
picks up based on the way they described
the character so this is probably after
she's washed out of West Point after
she's had her years abroad while she was
sort of training to become bat woman
then she comes back to Gotham is sort of
this narrow do well and this downward
spiral as a society girl she runs into
Renee Montoya who arrests her for
driving under the influence then
eventually ends up fighting off some of
her attackers before Batman shows up and
he sort of inspires her to become a
vigilante too so it wasn't a Robin
situation where initially like Batman
went out found Dick Grayson then he
became Robin
Kate Kane did all this on her own her
father a colonel in the military is the
one that armors her up so she has access
to all this military tech so that's
where all of her toys come from like
it's a bit of a Gambia situation because
Kate Kane works with her father to
collect information using a lot of
military intelligence early on in her
career she doesn't really work with
Batman that much if you've been reading
any of the rebirth comics she did have a
pretty big arc with the Batman family
training a bunch of vigilantes in Gotham
then because she's one of the few
characters that actually does use guns
that's one of the big things about her
character that's different from
traditional Batman ethos is that she's
willing to kill people
so Batman's always having to tell her to
pump the brakes she's actually getting
ready to be kicked out of the bat family
for killing Clayface even though it
seemed justified in the moment it's one
of those situations whereby you argue
with the heroes like was there another
way to deal with this so you have to
imagine she has that tragic origin story
whereby a she nor sister were kidnapped
as children her sister was killed by the
kidnappers during the rescue attempt so
that feeling of inadequacy and survivor
guild just lived with her through her
time at West Point while she was busy
becoming a badass then
night in the alley where she had the
idea to become that woman after Batman
saved her from those attackers that was
the tipping point where she's like
that's it no more this is [ __ ]
so you have to imagine that because CW
bat woman seems like she's relatively
early in her career she still has that
huge chip on her shoulder the
description for the character makes her
sound like she could be a little bit
stabby er than Oliver when we first meet
her like you know like Oliver had a
problem with killing people during
season one and that sort of came back to
bite them in the ass during season five
when prometheus came for him the
official logline for her character that
they've released is armed with a passion
for social justice and a flair for
speaking her mind kake ain't Sora's onto
the streets of Gotham as Batwoman
in out lesbian in a highly trained
street fighter primed to sing about the
failing city's criminal resurgence but
don't call her hero yet in a city
desperate for a savior Kate must
overcome her own demons before embracing
the call to be Gotham's symbol of hope
so it should be said everybody asking
about Batman I did a flash arrow
crossover video a couple of days ago
because the CW did this big panel of the
TCAs were they updated on the status of
the Batwoman TV show and all the other
TV shows they confirmed that Batman
does exist in this universe because of
Oliver's name drops so it's earth one
Batman that they were talking about
implying that the Gotham that her TV
show will take place in is in earth one
but they said there's no plans to have
Batman star in the episode so they'll
have some way of referencing him because
if she's been Batwoman for a little
while then she's already run into Batman
because he would know if someone was
flying around the city wearing his
symbol he would pay them a visit to see
what their intentions are but I have a
feeling that he's just leaving her to do
her own thing as long as she doesn't
cross the line too much he doesn't mind
other vigilantes as long as they adhere
to his code of conduct and that means no
killing people so I wouldn't be
surprised if they trade on some of the
moments from arrow season 1 and be
Oliver has been through this giant arc
so presumably by the episode 9 crossover
episode he'll be out of prison and he'll
be able to tell her like look I know you
like to kill criminals because they're
terrible but trust me karma is a [ __ ]
in the funny thing about Oliver too is
that even though they've been through
that giant arc and now he's like yeah
it's definitely better to not kill
people he still struggles internally
over whether or not to kill whoever it
is that he's going after a week-to-week
if he's been at it for almost seven
years now and it's still a problem for
him imagine how much of a problem it's
going to be for Batwoman because she
uses a lot of guns during the series but
this is just a clip from the Batman bad
blood movie that gives you a pretty good
idea for where the character is that the
person that's voicing this is the
Avant's troughs key from the Chuck
series investigative report on that
woman her father is Colonel Jacob Kane
military intelligence on Catherine's
twelfth birthday she and her twin sister
Elizabeth were abducted along with their
mother Gabrielle and held for ransom
Colonel Kane led a rescue mission that
saved Kate's life but in the attempt
both Gabrielle and Elizabeth were
murdered she would follow in her
father's footsteps enrolling at West
Point but ultimately expelled something
broke inside Kate
two years later Katherine emerged as
Batwoman she's impressive but her
methods make her a danger to this city
so post all your reactions in the
comments below there's a whole bunch of
Avengers a whole bunch of Deadpool stuff
dropping I'll try to get through all
those videos as fast as possible leave
your requests in the comments below
click here to learn about all the
details that they revealed about the
flash season 5 at that big panel a
couple days ago and click here for brand
new Deadpool 2 deleted scenes and banned
jokes thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]